[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
really excited to be talking about
cataloging and navigating consciousness
we have the quality of research
institute team joining us hello guys
hello hi hello everyone hello welcome
back this is our third episode of
quality research it's you're very
excited you guys are doing some of the
most important work in neuroscience and
consciousness today and I'm very excited
to have you guys back this time we have
Romeo joining us as well very excited to
have you on and we have Kenneth and
Quintin joining us as well hello hello
and Andres and Mike of course from the
previous episodes as you guys know all
right so let's jump into things with
understanding what it means to even
explore the state state of consciousness
in the first place to see this beautiful
catalogue of what is possible with state
spaces of consciousness we have great
graphics as we go through yeah yeah yeah
so well this graphic is actually pretty
pretty loose turret if so that's a
that's what's called the color space CA
lab specifically so basically what you
can do is use combinations of lights
like for example you know a red a green
blue light with different like
amplitudes different energies and see
basically how much you need to change
the lights for a person to experience
what's called a just noticeable
difference in their experience of color
right so it's kind of you're comparing
two side by side two colors and it's
like are they exactly the same or
there's subtly different and if they're
subtly different you you count that as a
unit a unit of a just noticeable
difference and you start using that as
your ruler it's kind of like oh you use
the just noticeable difference it's kind
of a ruler and you start to kind of like
peen all of the values of experience
that way in the case of color you end up
with that three-dimensional space
basically has three
dimensions it has the blue yellow axis
the rain red green axis and that has
like the brighter and darker axis and
it's fabulous that it turns out to be a
Euclidian 3d space it could have been
different the paradigm doesn't impose a
Euclidean geometry to it the Euclidian
property seems to be kind of an
intrinsic feature of the stiffness of
color but this is just just with color
in principle you can do these with
flavors and smells and sense of touch
and emotions and you can basically
generalize it in order to make a map of
all types of Aquila Quilliam varieties
basically Aquila variety is a type of
Aquila a type of consciousness
we're like for example like really a
variety could be the variety of color
these would be the state space of color
you can also have this case of you know
emotions and and scents and textures yes
and I think like the the next slide
actually might be a it's kind of like a
good example of the States based on
emotions yeah I know you try to kind of
look at the matter
yeah grief sadness right ecstasy yeah
yeah and I mean they're all related in
interesting ways and the question is how
do you put them in a map so that their
relationships in how they feel are in a
sense encoded in the geometry of that
map yes I mean as I said like in the
case of color you can have a 3d
Euclidean space for emotion is more
complicated you may need something like
a hyperbolic space you can get away with
Euclidean space for some things but not
for everything okay so let's start
unpacking this so one of the things that
it thinks really relatable right there
off the bat is when we see color so we
see one shade of blue and then we just
opposed it with another shade of blue
and we we don't let's say we if it's no
units of difference then we believe that
the states made of space of
consciousness is the same if it's no
units of difference but if there is a
single unit of difference or ten unit
of difference which you're trying to
measure with like this ruler that you're
describing in the space then then you
could say that the states made of
consciousness changes in the mind and
then is there then a if you move only
one unit versus if you move ten units
would there be a more like a more subtle
smaller change for one unit and a little
bit bigger change in the state space for
yeah I would I mean kind of like a
worded as by changing your consciousness
you're accessing different regions of
the state space of consciousness in some
sense as tasteless or conscious never
never changes it just it is kind of like
the universal map of all possible
experiences but yeah if you just take
your experience and you just modify one
shade of color in one piece of your
visual field
mm-hmm that will be making one step in
that very high dimensional state space
of consciousness you can do much more
radical transformations of course if you
change the entirety of your visual field
or you know you change your experience
or state of consciousness you would be
moving much further but yes but in a
sense the status of consciousness never
changes is a feature of the universe
okay yes and then now we gave the
example of color as part of a visual
input stream then we started giving this
massive amount of emotions that
different people can feel there's so
many other ones of these so scent is
another one so you have to catalogue the
state space percent they catalog the
state space for taste for touch and for
audio and for all these emotions and
visions that we talked about and then
you have to if someone is experiencing
two of these different of maybe a visual
and and an auditory or visual and a
taste at the same time I mean this gets
super complicated super quick with the
states basic consciousness like the silo
off the state space of consciousness for
all these different sensory inputs and
then you also try and figure out when
two of them work together or when four
of them work together ya know it's a
but you might recall kind of a
combinatorial explosion as soon as it
started introducing more clearly a
varieties and and the other the truth
seems to be that there's like some
constraints between them but they're
definitely not intuitive
you definitely have you know people with
synesthesia for example who naturally
are able to bind together for example at
sensations of sound together with the
sensations of color which is something
that most people can't and that is also
you know a component of the status of
consciousness is which of the qualia
varieties can be bound together in your
experience and that's another kind of
like area to explore like basically what
is the space of possible ways of binding
different qualia varieties I mean we
humans are kind of have a natural or
like a typical way of binding it which
seems to be evolutionarily advantageous
but in some sense we could say that
we're all seem aesthetic it is that we
are basically experiencing an
evolutionarily advantageous type of
synesthesia and then is within if we can
get at least I think more people to try
to be aware of how a different stimuli
is then causing us them to have a
specific state space of consciousness so
as long as we're becoming more conscious
of okay a certain stimuli it's a certain
state space of consciousness you know
when I feel good it's a certain way when
I feel bad it's something else's state
space here when I see blue certain thing
when I see red certain thing when it
smells something certain things so if
you can at least start getting people to
become more conscious about I think that
gets the catalogue more and more and
then do we have another asset with with
this I mean that gets into the
navigation okay let's be beautiful let's
shift right into navigation man so we
explained the catalog so let's talk
about navigating between because some
usually it's kind of like we're just
going through and then all of a sudden
we become happier or we smell something
or we taste something yeah touch
something I'll just briefly mention this
light and then somebody else to jump in
but it's
what that slide represents yeah yeah
it's the this is from research I did in
grad school which was mapping out the
transition probability between different
emotions so we took like 170 emotions
and we interactive you know messy
amounts of people we ended up having
like more than a million data points
about how people transition from one
emotion to the next yes we would build
models of like given your sequence of
previous emotions what other emotions
you're likely to go to in the future and
with this kind of map you find
fascinating features of the navigation
space because turns out that there's for
example these gateway emotions like for
example feeling hopeful feeling relieved
those are like it's not just kind of the
sensation of ever good or like you
positive valence if you feel hopeful or
you feel relieved that's a lot of
information about where you where in the
past and where you're moving towards so
there's kind of like all of these
topology as well of the gateways
emotions at Tractor emotions emotions
that basically are reflectors that they
don't for example feeling tired it
doesn't matter in what region of the
state space of consciousness you are
what emotions you were in most people
feel tired at some point of the day not
everybody but most people tired is not a
very high information emotion but
hopefulness is a very high information
emotion it tells you a lot about the
trajectory of the person whoa yeah this
huge so it's harder to get from
something that's like an edge point past
like cheerfulness or excitedness to
something that's like annoyed or yeah
it's harder to get from edge point edge
points usually you have to go through
these main center yeah way points yes
then gain more information from certain
points about trajectory and past that
yeah can about otherwise it's kind of
like a map of how to navigate it - yeah
it's like if you want to go to a very
different emotion you know it's like
what oh yeah you know empirically what
what is like the typical transitions
between emotions that will get
there yeah it's also very important to
note that some of these experiences some
of these emotions are more pleasant than
others by by far yeah and a part of
navigation a part of sort of mapping is
understanding this and understanding
that a good map tells you where the good
places to go are as well in in the
Middle Ages allegedly this might be true
or just a story but in these old maps
they had marked here be dragons where
people went and didn't come back from or
there were big troubles and this is I
mean yeah in terms of mapping
consciousness we are absolutely in the
early days here but yeah there are bad
places in the state space of
consciousness and we need navigational
principles in order to understand where
not to go and I feel that's a core part
of there's research there be dragons in
anxiety and depression and suicide yep
dragons they're absolute little horses
so how do we avoid or or kill the
Dragons yeah how do we navigate away
from yeah that state space yeah by
cataloging and then helping
move with little dissonance in those
directions okay
other thoughts on navigation bring to
you guys yes sir it's Michael is
alluding to I think that having a map of
the state space of consciousness also
allows us to compare experiences in
terms of their valence so like for
example one of the worst experiences
known to humans is cluster headache
which is an extremely extremely severe
headache often rated a 10 out of 10 on
the pain scale so being able to quantify
the valence the negative valence
associated with those kinds of
experiences and comparing them to others
allows us to determine which experiences
are the ones that we want to avert the
most yeah and I think that it also
allows us on the other side of the
equation to say there are probably
states of consciousness which no one has
ever experienced over the course of
human history which would be really
great to explore and having this map
would allow us to in a principled way
sort of know what direction we're going
and have a North Star of positive
valence and yeah I think that's like
something that we could definitely
explore further to headaches in the
world to those states as conscious that
have not even been explored that are
extremely positive yeah and there may be
a very simple set of equations that
describe how to get from that between
those two points and yeah just in
general a lot is at stake in figuring
this off
yeah for Hopa and hopefully in forms
that are decentralized open-source and
loving compassionate ways and not yeah
overly like the manipulative corrupt
yeah ways yeah
romeo thoughts on catalog and navigating
feeling good
[Laughter]
alright beautiful so what does it mean
to have no dissonance in between the
navigation of the state space of
consciousness so this leads into this
theory of emotional valence that this
theory of what makes an experience good
and what makes an experience bad and so
cure is our hypothesis here is called
the symmetry theory of valence and it's
this idea that if we have a mathematical
representation of what it feels like to
be you Alan or what it feels like to me
like that if we the the pleasantness or
unpleasantness of that experience should
somehow be encoded into this
mathematical object this mathematical
representation and we we believe the the
encoding is in this objects symmetry so
so more symmetrical with the states of
consciousness that are really
pleasurable and less symmetrical with
the headache yes yes and a kind of a
simple way to put this is harmony in the
brain feels good
dissonance in the brain feels bad and is
this true that the extreme headache
states are like extremely there's a kind
of like a lot of like lines of evidence
pointing towards it not specifically for
cluster headaches that hasn't been
studied in in that way but when it comes
to like all sorts of perceptual
artifacts that come from like negative
states of consciousness and how to
induce them
yeah there's kind of a suggestion that
it has
do with this concept of like roughness
and easements we actually have a an
example over there it's actually not
completely fair so yeah so yeah well if
you look at the the spectrum there's a
spectrum picture right yes that one okay
that's the that's the spectrum of the
part I think I believe like between 24th
Street and mission and and Balboa Park
one of the most unpleasant sounds known
to man oh it's the high-pitched
screeching noise winded yeah it's a it's
kind of like peach I mean it really has
like it's horrible component to between
like 400 pairs and 500 with some like
upper registers as well of these
yeah I think it's
yeah
turn it up no we can hear it a little
yeah but it's good it's good I think I
think you played the bad parts I think I
think we're good thank you yeah so is it
I mean it's it's a very very
straightforward example of how a
physical process that almost maximizes
roughness can really heart your mellow I
mean it's really a buzzkill to be in the
bar like you're having fun with your
friends and all of a sudden easily okay
yeah incredible speech and you know a
lot of people would be very puzzled
about like hey like why is it so bad and
that's like something that we are trying
to answer we were being developing
basically algorithms that can take
sounds like that and say yeah that's
really horrible for for a number of good
reasons having to do we like the
mathematical roughness of it the lack of
invariance and symmetry and I mean I
would add that I mean hacking your
emotions through sound is one of the
most straightforward ways mostly because
the the number of pre-processing steps
between auditory stimuli and brain state
are very few as opposed to for example
pre-processing between visual stimuli
and brain state so auditory stimuli the
shape of it is gonna be very related to
the actual shape of the brain state that
is triggered by by it so in a sense kind
of like the the structure of a sound is
gonna be kind of a window into into how
it's gonna affect the structure of your
brain state you can tell a lot about
what braces are good or bad based on the
structure of the sound the trigger is
good or bad feelings okay and then what
would then if this is on the side of
extreme dissonance and you could be in a
very symmetrical state and then
experience a super dissonance and then
that
you could map you know how that actually
affects someone's states various
conscious what would be an example of
the most symmetrical the states well in
in music there's definitely a lot of
examples I mean not to sound all whole
new age but enniaa for example if you
run it through the sort of software
we're developing it comes out as like
very very very consonant very very very
symmetrical over time I mean like the
sound engineering involved in like any
ax songs it's kind of really hitting the
spot when it comes to like maximizing
consonants and like all of these like
reverb effects as well but for any ax
and yeah yeah and E and E and Y a yes
and yeah and yeah a boy a boys gotta you
know dive into other space bases of
consciously but I mean for example like
a Buddhist singing bows as well those
are like highly highly consonant oh yeah
analyze them yeah
and generally speaking the chorus the
chorus part of songs tends to be very
much in the direction of very high
consonants which is kind of like the
part that tends to be the most photonic
of a song the reason why songs are not
just chorus is because that would get
boring and basically if you trigger
boredom then that will itself cause a
little bit of dissonance you will fail
to appreciate it but if it's like dosed
high amounts of consonants like in the
chorus of a song then you can really get
into it just to set the frame we're
working on ways to evaluate the
consonants the harmony in sounds as well
as the dissonance with the eye toward if
we can do it to sounds there is also a
method to do it to reigns to actually
evaluate in a precise mathematical sense
how much harmony is in a brain state
and you could hypothetically imagine a
world in which the barter would sound
very consonant if you properly employ
these algorithms that you're developing
I think kind of an important question
here that a lot of people ask similarly
to can't we feel good all the time is
well if we need these if we only have
these pockets of consonants in popular
music is it required for us to have the
dissonance in between those pockets of
consonants in order for the sound to be
pleasurable and hard our contention is
that you don't necessarily have to
employ dissonance in order to achieve
contrast and so I think that's an
important thing for people to understand
too is that you don't necessarily have
to suffer in order to appreciate the
contrast to feeling good you can sort of
start at zero and go to infinity rather
than having negative infinity to
positive infinity
yeah but that that one's really
important actually one of the I think
things that have been has been in debate
in the last couple of years with our
with our friends has been that do we
really need to experience suffering in
order to understand what is on the
positive infinity side of things to be
able to actually have something to
contrast it with to be grateful for and
stuff and potentially one of the
hypothesis is that don't the the frame I
would offer is that empirically human
brains seem to kind of be built this way
that we tend to oscillate between
suffering and pleasure and there does
seem to be some some useful thing we as
humans get from that but it doesn't seem
to be a law of the universe that you
have to suffer to feel good that there
is this hedonic balance and presumably
we could if we're if for making a new
organism from scratch we wouldn't have
to program in that the organism would
have to suffer okay and let's on a
little bit more on this symmetry theory
of valence let's explain more about how
exactly we can do things like
potentially having a mathematical
representation of a state space of
consciousness that is symmetrical yeah I
think the next slide potential might be
that
that's this one yeah well this is kind
of like illustrates wasn't meant to be a
video but otherwise okay no no okay it's
going oh it's sweet yeah so those are
the the harmonic states of a plate this
is called a clammy plate basically if
you make it vibrate with like a speaker
for example at a certain frequency
cymatics yes I Maddox exactly it's gonna
basically lock in into a nearby resonant
mode and the really cool thing is that
there's only an integer number of
possible resonant modes there there's
there's not an infinite number of shapes
you can make and the reason why is that
there's only a certain number of ways in
which kind of this mechanical wave can
fit an integer number of times in the
shape of the plate
so in a sense you can like discretize
this is already getting very tight okay
as well so we're saying that the amount
of symmetrical states are the number of
resonant modes resonant modes are
limited and then they get any given
point in time you're experiencing a
weighted sum of many resonant modes okay
basically the division is the equations
to tell you what shapes form on this
plate this so you basically sprinkle
salt or sugar on these gladdening plates
and then you you can kind of visualize
the waves and the same equations which
predict the shapes at different
frequencies are the same equations we're
applying to the brain okay so if I'm at
345 Hertz and that's making a
symmetrical state for me that may be
through a process of something like I'm
meditating or I'm experiencing a form of
symmetry of flow State or listening to
the course of the music whatever it may
be right so then the same way that you
visualize salt or or sugar in
symmetrical stayed on that could be the
same way that that same mathematical
equation could be of what and so I'm
trying to keep that state I'm trying to
hold on when people get lost in the flow
state or deep in their meditation that
they're just extending and extending
that period and then so they've
basically been having that same equation
happen for a period of time right I mean
in a sense it's gonna make the higher
the valence which is the fact the more
pleasant the state is it's kind of like
a function of the total consonants like
it's basically the the the way in which
those harmonics are interacting do they
get together are they interfering in a
in a positive way or are the
interference term destructive way and
one key there is that in a sense like
the the richness of your experience
would have to do with how many of those
harmonics are able to fit in a consonant
way I mean is that there's a difference
between just hearing you know a melody
played with like two or three notes in a
piano versus a whole Orchestra and
there's like a whole you know R is a
whole art and science to how to feed a
whole Orchestra of instruments into
something that sounds good when you have
like all of these different frequency
channels and different timbres and
different ways of softening the sound
and like why is like a peak experience
is not just a necessarily a pure simple
you know resonant mode where is more
kind of this assembly of resonant modes
that fit really well together and this
would look a little more scattered if it
wasn't a dissonant state yes be any
symmetry that right roughly it would
look rough unbalanced and constantly
changing okay and yeah just to offer a
little context Cheers
so that's what suffering is rough
untalented let's let me change it yeah
it's kind of like turbulence yeah
they're like turbulent turbulence all
right yeah turbulence is a good metaphor
for this yeah FinCEN talks about
turbulence suffering as well and just to
offer some context here this is based
off the work of
a neuroscientist by the name of seven de
SOI she is at Oxford and the paradigm is
called connectome specific harmonic
waves and it's a way of interpreting
neural imaging existing techniques fMRI
DTI MRI and adding it together to figure
out the brains natural residences just
like a guitar or piano or a wineglass
has these natural resonances this is a
way of measuring them in a brain and
what we're doing is we're building on
top of this analyzing this data and then
the idea is then that if you can then
start doing things like conducting like
fMRI scans of symmetrical states of
consciousness then you can start
cataloging and when you can start
cataloging and you can make that that
beautiful representations yeah I'm sure
I mean I think one very very important
frame here is what you can measure you
can manage and if this is a tight proxy
for how pleasant the brain state is then
it lets us understand if a brain if if a
person is in pain if they are suffering
it allows us to pinpoint where is the
suffering coming from because we can
look at the mathematics of the the
frequencies and the distance and say oh
it's this specific harmonic it's the
frequency is drifted or it's oscillating
in a strange way or
whatnot and it allows us to calculate
the turbulence that's occurring right
right yeah and figure out how to fix it
basically okay yeah yeah go ahead yeah
sure rascal just gonna mention we've
talked a lot about human brains here but
this paradigm could also be applied to
non-human animals as well and it could
be a really interesting way to directly
scientifically determine whether or not
animals were suffering because I think
that is a question that is on a lot of
people's minds and there are some people
who think that non-human animals are not
capable of suffering and this might be a
way to determine that actually are and
even even further in the future maybe
it's something that could be used on on
other other types of brains on
artificial intelligence for example to
determine what what state is that AI or
what state is this animal in and how do
we fix that for them in addition to
ourselves yeah yeah there's also even
even the pulled even like a plant for if
the plant is is housing insects eat it
or isn't having the right nutrients in
the soil or sunlight and starting to die
I mean is that then an expression of
consciousness dying aren't hard to say
this one hard to say at this point yeah
yeah I would all the way up to the AI
this method can be applied to literally
any we're gonna organism with neurons
assuming that there's a some proxy
relationships and plants have only cells
they don't tender ones clients have only
cells but you can see a stress response
happening in the plant when it gets yeah
yeah no no not to get to talk to them
here I'll just throw this this is not
necessarily Qri line this is more an
argument by David Pierce we've we've
talked briefly about it but one reason
why plants are not as I mean they could
be conscious we don't know but
definitely there's the the purely
physiological component that the cells
are divided by thick cellulose walls so
whatever is the the mechanism of action
for binding for neurons actually talking
to each other and being able to
synchronize with each other that doesn't
seem physically possible between the
cells of a plant okay but who knows okay
so it's potentially how neurons are able
to communicate with each other with more
thin the transmitters that that type of
the yeah mission that makes it yeah
versus the thick walls of plant cells
okay so I'm the nonhuman animal aspect
that in humans we see there's this
strong factor of default atomic setpoint
some people go through life just happier
than others
some people had very high not acceptable
some people had very low in minutes and
this is this is very interesting that
even within humans you find an enormous
range of hedonic set points and it's
interesting to think about if you see
this amount of variance within humans
how much variance will there be between
species and maybe it turns out it's just
pretty fantastic to be a dog yeah or
dolphins are just totally ecstatic right
something right
and maybe it's just terrible to be a
giraffe or Clara Mouse yeah someone
that's constantly in fear being consumed
by another animal yeah yep so in the
sense it could move the the whole field
of understanding non-human sentience or
non-human
I guess wild animal suffering or whatnot
yeah to a more quantitative basis yeah
like to be able to say that a specific
animal has has a tendency to move
towards specific state spaces
consciousness and other ones have
different tendencies that's really cool
stuff to now so people need to help fun
do you guys so you can do the fMRI scans
of symmetry and dissonance that's the
next that's the big stuff that's right
yeah that's a we were describing as kind
of a very high information experiment I
mean we are currently collecting what
you might describe as kind of like low
information or medium information
experiments which in a sense like they
add up and of course if you have enough
weak evidence that definitely builds a
very strong case but in science usually
how paradigms change is when somebody
makes a really weird prediction and then
they actually go ahead and test it and
it turns out like the other prediction
is correct yeah and that's that's one of
the cases of for example putting people
in fMRI with MDMA and then computing the
consonance of their brain harmonics
there's no other theory that is
predicting that would have anything to
do with pleasure and pain so that's kind
of like the case of really weird really
weird prediction very high information
if it turns out true that said we are
not completely constrained by that I
mean the the research were aggregating
currently it is building up the case
over time but of course we would love to
just like you know jump to the cut to
the chase and and see what happens in
there yes
yeah I could a maybe even got to maybe
the the last slide yeah just to kind of
give you give you like an example of
what we consider a moderate evidence for
the symmetry theory valence is moderate
because is through EEG and of course
like there's not a really great theory
of what EEG is measuring but if you
interpreted through the light of
connecting harmonics these makes a lot
of sense so what this is showing is okay
so like the basically took EEG
recordings high quality AG recordings of
a person on five mio DMT which is
described as one of the most intense but
also most blissful and terrifying states
of consciousness but basically very very
very high valence which is like God
molecule yeah basically people rate it
as like ten out of ten in the dimension
of significance as I'm it feels very
significant so clearly if there's like a
signature of aliens you would expect to
see it on five Mao DMT and what this
research shows is that if you take the
the EEG signatures of a person and
Faramir DMT and you filter by the gamma
band and the gamma is usually associated
with heightened states of consciousness
like orgasm basically high arousal high
energy states once you filter the EEG
through the gamma band and you start
seeing the the phase correlation between
the different channels you will see that
on five mio DMT just maxes out basically
all the channels are in phase coherence
in some sense you can almost think of it
as like there's this forty Hertz
vibration electromagnetic vibration
throughout the entire brain in synchrony
and like why would that be associated
with a sense of profound sense of
significance if synchrony and symmetry
didn't have anything to do with valence
that you could probably round it up with
some other theories potentially but and
that's why this is not necessarily kind
of the
the Silver Bullet but we consider it
like yeah a moderate piece of evidence
and if we assemble enough of these I
think the case is gonna be pretty strong
and yeah back on the funding angle it's
this question of finding people who are
very comfortable with weird ideas and
potentially incredibly transformative
ideas that have have a solid rationale
but are sort of outside the Overton
Window of what generally gets funded so
yeah we're always on the lookout for
sort of high-quality donors this is
complicated what you're describing is
extremely complicated and yeah to be
able to take a high-quality eg recording
and then to be able to just analyze the
gamma and then to be able to take in an
analysis of the hyper symmetry of it was
a 10 on this on impact or well
significant significant some significant
significance yeah yeah yeah it's
definitely true for a lot of the
experiences Romeo you're trying to go
the whole show without talking I know
[Laughter]
they're all doing such a great job see
the mr. perfection okay and a couple
other assets that we want to show can we
show the one right after the cymatics
Ronnie the one like a couple assets back
just a couple the very first white one
in that row in the row yep yep that one
yep yeah so I just want to show these
quick yeah I think this is important
this is kind of like the the catalog of
the state space of consciousness you can
be extremely true
this will be basically cataloguing I
mean how we were describing you know
take the color state-space right or take
like the flavor stick space this would
be basically getting at the root of the
emotional state space so this is when
you'd be tasting something that's like
really I don't know spicy I don't know
like ah like what would be well yeah you
a little yeah sure like sighing pain for
example like when you this like one hot
sauce then that like makes them cry yeah
yeah sure sure or physical pain or
emotional pain basically it just like
highly negative aliens well actually
yeah what this is suffering what this is
describing is kind of like a way of
visualizing the dissonance between
harmonics okay
these are reasoning right these are each
different harmonics and if you want to
explain that
sure harmonics the size of the bubble is
kind of like the amplitude how much
energy each of these harmonics has and
then the arrows are basically whether
they're like mutually consonant or
dissonant with each other and I mean in
music when you're analyzing the
dissonance of like simple instruments
being put together basically what you do
is you compute the pairwise dissonance
of all the pure tones in the spectrum
and that gives you kind of the global
dissonance score which basically yeah I
can account for like subjective ratings
of dissonance here is kind of like
taking the same idea but applying it to
brain harmonics so you take like for
every pair of brain harmonics you see
whether they're like decent anthro
consonant you aggregate all that all the
dissonance and that it would be kind of
a general measure of how bad the
experience feels then you add up all the
consonants and that's kind of a general
measure of how good it feels
anyhow like that's what the the our
theory is predicting specifically it
gives you so this is adding up all the
all the pairwise distance relations this
is the pairwise constants relations
pairwise Milius relations and it gives
you a position in a valence space
okay and one more time for one more time
again give that give that bit again with
the yeah yeah yeah so the the red is
adding up all the pairwise distance
relationships between these natural
brain harmonics okay and you just
aggregate them add them up and then the
blue is the pairwise consonant relation
and then this is the pairwise noise
relationship gray ones okay all right
and it gives you if you sort of add them
up it gives you a position on this state
space s base okay and yeah for just for
clarity that triangle right is like
where people say like are you feeling
good or bad oftentimes people say like I
don't know and the reason why is because
usually typical emotions typical typical
emotional states are mixed you have for
example your your a concert you're
enjoying the music and your friends but
then like the speakers are not really
good and then like you also need to go
pee and you're kind of drunk and like
okay this is very complicated mix the
state so that would be kind of like in
the middle right it has like some
positive valence components of negative
and some neutral and that's why together
next time like self-report is pretty
difficult because it's so so mixed
usually okay because there's all these
these pair which compare paralyze your
hair wise relationships okay and they're
all kind of pulling a little bit on the
neutral around the pleasure on the
distance exactly yeah okay yeah I think
a way to relate this to the state space
of color against I think that's one
that's like pretty well understood by
people there's one way to create colors
is to create certain RGB values and so
you sort of have like the red zone scale
from 0 to 255 ringing scale from 0 to
255 blues carefully
fifty-five and then you sort of mix
different values of r g and b to get a
certain color as an output i think the
metaphor kind of works here too where
you know you have these three values of
constants distance and noise you're sort
of mixing them to get a certain knock
color but certain emotional state and so
I think that's kind of a way to yeah
that's a good one down the line yeah
that's one of the people I think are
really familiar with people know about
color okay excellent
and let's um let's wrap on this point I
want to bring this up so during the last
talk that I went to that you guys were
hosting I really enjoyed this that a lot
of people are either kind of stuck in
their own in their own bodies
identifying with their own selves and
nothing really outside of themselves
some people try and understand their
whole like timeline all the way back to
their past and they're born all the way
to their future where they're trying to
go so they kind of get it on the whole
timeline scale and then this and also
excuse me and also where the world is at
as well in those periods of years as
well so from like if you're born in 2000
and so 2080 so I'm that chunk of time
versus this idea of like all that is or
infinity or love or infinite
consciousness there's so many ways to
describe this God etc source and when
one potentially taps into things like
these super symmetrical states that they
may experience that they may experience
dives into all that is and so some
people can trigger that just through
breath and just by expanding themselves
out as fast as the universe and I think
that's a very beautiful way to get there
and so this sounds it sounds it sounds
great to be able to Evan flow between
all three of those and that's something
that I think was a
beautifully said by you you go ahead and
yeah explain that more to us I like that
a lot
yeah I mean we do seem to kind of like
come into this world with implicit views
of who we are but they're like given by
evolution they're not necessarily true
they're just pragmatically useful I mean
this sense of a you start existing when
you're born you stop existing when you
die is usually a unexamined assumption
of course people try to extend it and
say well maybe you don't die really you
continue to exist as a soul after you
you die or maybe you there was a ring
carnation most people still think of it
as kind of just a single line and you're
in a sense like separate from the rest
of the universe those like alternative
views that can be justified and there's
this view called empty individualism
where you're just like this moment of
experience and in a moment in a second
you're gonna be a different entity or
rather a different entity will inhabit
your body because you were just that
slice and then there's like this view
called open individualism which is that
we're all one consciousness like we are
all kind of these meta meta organism
looking at itself from different points
of view and I think like really the
those are you can describe the Mosel as
like states of consciousness you can
definitely in some states of very
neutral experience you can just feel
that you're just at time slice a very
classical way you're feeling that we're
all one consciousness is in psychedelics
and meditation I mean five Meo is a
classic example of people it really
creates the feeling that you're all
consciousness and there's like this
interplay between the information
content of the experience and how
cleanly defined you are so like 5ml DMT
or any of these like super symmetrical
states it's so symmetrical so invariant
it contains close to no information so
there's just not enough information to
know who you are so you identify with
the light of consciousness or the void
or universal mind I think like a yeah
that kind of state and especially if you
can like logically and and precisely
shift between those that's gonna be
really important for a global
coordination where you're gonna have
like see
of companies or leaders of different
countries identify with consciousness
rather than with you know their cultural
background or who they are then yeah I
think like they can collaborate to
basically raise the baseline of
everybody it's a possibility
yeah damn that's that bad section right
there is a whole nother all right so for
those that were watching we would love
for you to give us your thoughts in the
comments below and the episode let us
know what you're thinking check out the
links in the bio to quality research
institutes website as well as the other
resources that you find the links below
also support the artists entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe and support them help them
grow support quiet Research Institute
helped them get funding for the research
that they need to get done also support
simulation our links are below to our
patreon paypal cryptocurrency link
support us help us grow and share more
content about this type of stuff with
your friends and families co-workers
people online on social media about
cataloging and navigating consciousness
really get talking more about this and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in
we will see you soon peace
[Music]